the other piece of all this is critical
to any democracies is the rule of law
and in very basic ways we don't make it
so that our courts work for people who
don't have a lot of money for example if
you have committed a crime you have a
right to a lawyer that's called
beginning in case but if you are
somebody who has a risk of losing your
home or losing your child you don't have
a right to a civil lawyer we don't do it
nearly enough to help people get access
to lawyers in court when it makes all
the difference in the world none of us
would voluntarily walk in and risk
losing our child without a lawyer but a
lot of people just can't afford the
lawyer so we are engaged at the Brennan
Center and a big push to try to make
more legal services available to the
poor to lift some of the restrictions on
the legal services corporation that
helps provide law and legal services for
poor people there's a justice gap in the
country where many many Americans simply
don't have access to the benefits of the
justice system and that if we want to
have a real working democracy that's got
to be part of the answer the government
should be doing it and the private bar
should be doing it and private business
should be doing it we there's no
necessarily one answer you know not
every problem deserves a lawyer but
there are just basic ways that we could
be spending not much more money but
having a much bigger impact on helping
those people in these high stakes
matters we ever eat is someone said if
if you rob a bank you have a right to a
lawyer if the bank robs you you're out
of luck when we see the consequence of
the subprime mortgage disaster where
millions of Americans are at risk of
losing their homes very often for for
things that were no fault of their own
and they don't have a lawyer that's
crazy
you